almost everybody who is successful would
count us in this new pathologizing era
as a workaholic but it's not common that
people who actually are self-made and
successful have a lot of me time the
most obvious example I give in the
column is Elon Musk people sort of think
it's it's weird that that that that that
Elon Musk slept on the floor of one of
his Tesla factories when he was trying
to get the the model through well that's
an example of somebody who would qualify
as a workaholic but he also produced the
most successful non- diesel powerered
car and is currently try working to get
to Mars and that's not somebody who
really needs to put their feet up a lot
more or have a lot more me time that's
somebody who's doing stuff and that's
admirable I don't think it should be
sort of medicalized